Okay, so before we hop into actually setting up our natural light and scene, I wanted to
give an overview of Lumen and essentially take a look at and highlight some of the features
that it comes with.
So Lumen is a default lighting system inside of Unreal Engine 5, which is a fully dynamic
global illumination system, like I mentioned before.
It gives us performance reflections and they're actually supported in clear coat materials,
which are important for car paint.
It's compatible with large open worlds, and as I said before, it's all real time, so there's
no light baking, everything happening and streaming on the GPU.
It works really well on both outdoor and indoor scenes.
And one thing that's actually really nice is that emissive materials can contribute
to lighting the scene itself.
One of the limitations of Lumen is that the global illumination and sky shadowing will
give you lower quality with translucent materials and volumetric fog.
If you use world position offset in a material to displace some verts on a mesh, it can cause
artifacts.
There's no support for lighting channels.
It gives you poor mirror-like reflections, so that's something where you'd want to turn
on hardware ray tracing specifically for, which we'll take a look at.
This deformation in general with hardware ray tracing will give you high cost with skeletal
mesh, so anything like skeletal mesh animations, it'll have a high cost rendering those out.
And it's really only supported on high end PCs and next-gen consoles and not supported
on mobile or VR.
So that's something to keep in mind if you wanted to move your project to Lumen-based
scene, stuff to keep in mind in terms of the limitations.
Lumen will be enabled by default, but if for whatever reason you're changing from an old
project that wasn't using Lumen or for whatever reason it wasn't set up as default by Unreal
Engine, we're going to take a look at how we actually set this up.
So once again, hop back into the project and see how we'd enable these settings.
So to enable Lumen, all you'd have to do is go to Edit Project Settings.
Inside of this window, I'm just going to maximize it.
We're going to go to the Render tab inside of Engine.
I'm going to scroll down to Global Illumination.
So the Global Illumination setting needs to be set to Lumen if you want to use it, but
here's where if you wanted to use any other system, like standalone ray tracing or anything
like that, you could use that.
It's important to note as well that the reflection method in this case is set to Lumen.
And one thing that you want to do to make sure that Lumen works correctly is make sure
that Generate Mesh Distance Fields is turned off.
Now some additional settings that might give you some better results.
Within Lumen, you'll want to use hardware ray tracing when available.
So this is important to note that if you have a high-end GPU like an RTX card, this is somewhere
where you can use it.
If not, it's not worth digging this.
And inside of the hardware ray tracing, make sure that Support Hardware Ray Tracing is
actually ticked so that you get all the benefits from that as well.
Now importantly, you can change the behavior of all these things using post-process volume
so you don't have to change them project-wide every time.
So in order to do that, all we have to do is create a post-process volume.
So I'm going to go to the Place Actor tab here.
I'm going to search for Post, and I'll drag in a post-process volume.
Now in order, we already have one here, so I'm just going to go ahead and quickly delete
that.
And actually, that's actually changing some of our lighting settings here.
So let's go ahead and just use this one.
And there's a couple of things that you need to know to make sure that this post-process
volume actually affects your entire scene and not just the volume that it's represented.
So I'm going to go ahead and search here for Unbound.
And you can see here there's a tick box for infinite extent.
So make sure that that's ticked to ensure that that post-process becomes a global post-process
and affects the entire scene.
So in the case of the edits that we want to do for Lumen, or if you wanted to change any
of the settings, you want to go to the Global Illumination tab here.
And if you wanted to change it for other reasons, you could change it here.
And if you want to change the Insider Reflections, you can change the method as well to Lumen.
Okay.
And one last thing is that if you want to improve some of the quality of your scene,
and we're going to be talking quite minimized gains here as we go, but if you wanted to
update the final gather quality, if you want to bring this number up, it will reduce the
noise that you see in the scene, but it will greatly increase the cost.
So if you want to set this to 2, make sure that maybe the graininess that you might see
if you get really close gets fixed.
And really, I doubt it'll be easy to appreciate inside of the video that I'm making here.
But if you bring this value up, you'll see better quality and reduction of noise.
But again, just make sure you understand that this will significantly increase the cost
of rendering the scene and thus give you better, or sorry, poorer frame rates.
One last thing to note is that this is going to be mostly like the look of how Lumen actually
works.
It's going to be dictated by both the quality of the materials, the rest of the scene, and
also your exposure.
So if you, for example, have different exposure settings, you'll see Lumen adjust to that.
So just keep in mind that your exposure settings are going to affect the way the lighting scene
works as a whole.
So by default, I'm just going to tick game settings so it adjusts for me.
But just something to keep in mind once again.
Okay, I think we've covered everything we need to cover for Lumen.
I think we're ready to actually start setting up a natural lighting scene.
So let's go ahead and do that.